do you love me
i look like the hot bad boy
i'm like the most soft marshmallow soft
nice boy ever
i'm so pretty
i see
[Music]
hi everyone nice to meet you my favorite
food is pizza have a nice day what's
your name
[Music]
hi
hi
i'm always tired
okay i'm always tired
we don't lie we're doing it today
okay
[Laughter]
hi everyone
i
dino
um
hello what's something that most people
don't know about you i'm an angel and
you look like that hot bad boy i look
like the hot bad boy i'm like the most
soft marshmallow soft nice boy ever i
love rolly pops
he said that she will make us egg talk
i would really promise
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
thank you you're always angry
in games
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah i have six packs
seeing one of those monsters shouldn't
be
for
free
oh
it's free
i see you looking at my p.i.c
i see
yes
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh
please face and avocado because they
look so silly and dumb like me
[Music]
hearts
talk
one two three
[Music]
[Music]
i'm so tired
[Music]
[Laughter]
like
[Laughter]
from china next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
this
you could sing baby shark for two hours
and i'd still give you all my money baby
shark doo doo doo doo doo baby shark doo
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
what if you run your finger down one of
those abs it sounds like a xylophone
i'm going to say it
eric nam is daddy material go to bed
that's what daddy say right daddy mark
twain sir i'm just the whole and what do
you mean by that what do you
what do you want
we are of the same age but it's always a
dilemma whether i should call you baby
or daddy in my opinion
baby is better my mom does not approve
she's not a fan she literally told me
to tone down the sexiness she said too
much sexy
god is watching you sorry god
i lost my choker somewhere can i use
your
hand instead
[Music]
i'll let jackson went throw me down the
stairs and i'll thank him for even
touching me now come here i'll hug you
why does god pick everything
what what what otonge because i'm
like that happy it
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
love you oh
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you please
bye bye bye love you bye
[Music]
you